the thing that we learned is that
laptops when you unplug them everything
clocks down they don't run at full power
running laptops and by themselves on
your back not gonna work needed real
power real real energy density so now I
got laptops plugged into the running VR
when they're plugged in flawless now we
gotta trick the laptop and to thing
that's plugged in whoops trying to build
a backpack mounted PC because I really
wanted to play VR without wires I've
been trying to do this for years I don't
hate it again yeah it's kind of familiar
the old story I didn't have the right
hardware for it and now I do it so I'm
going to take this battery full charge
is twenty five point two volts I'm gonna
step it down to the nineteen point five
that that laptop requires it's a little
tricky I'll make sure I do it right
you run this battery into a step con
converter yeah we run step-down
converter through a power analyzer so I
can see how much amperage being pulled
through it and measure that out and out
and then I need to get the plug this
been the hardest part the plug for the
laptop this is an Origin laptop this is
this dang plug that can be I can't find
it it's female pin sockets on a male
plug so it's really hard to search for
it in Google because typing female or
male on the plug doesn't you'll do the
correct results I've narrowed it down to
that's brother component it's the Chi
con kpp X or the K ppj complete I
ordered a piece that might work am I not
you just solder wires soldering iron and
then need to solder plugs on the end of
the wire so plug it in if you're ever
buying a soldering iron get one that has
a temperature-controlled head basically
there's a thermostat in it it'll hold
the heat you need all the time they'll
never overheat and burn the solder on
the end or never
under heat it just holds the perfect
temperature 40 bucks congratulating the
usual like 10 or 20 you might pay it's
worth it it's worth every penny
it's really careful of this don't touch
I'm short each other out the bad news
must be a little extra safe so I put
some heat shrink tubing over the end of
this turn on this hairdryer you hold
this wire for me now the wire might get
hot okay okay
probably talking about this stuff like
what I talked about like film techniques
cuz I know I'm talking about when I talk
about visual effects and film techniques
where is they don't know I don't know
what I'm talking about
I talked about this and I'm still
figuring it out as I go so it's like
I've long pauses of silence while I try
to think about how I'm gonna solve a
problem such as here's the plug I've
been looking for for a long time I only
found it cost like 10 bucks just order
this one the bonds positive at the top
its negative for color it's positive red
and it's split across two pins because
the power drawl from the laptops so big
they need to get a 4 pin connector and
just have two of the pins through the
same thing for each half of it now now I
need to solder this 10 gauge wire to
these pins which are definitely not 10
gauge soldering pins
I can't overlap it I just start with
putting some solder in it
with a little bit of solder on your
soldering iron a little bit solder on
your connectors a little solder on your
wire that's the best way to do it got a
bridge both of these bottom pins with
this wire which I can do like this but I
can't have it touch the top pins it's
almost like I should just solder it to
the wire like that get a bunch of solder
that's all really toxic smoke and heat
up the wires and the wires they get hot
should wick away metal for my Sutter
name this isn't like exciting huge
problems here this is just there's just
care and attention put but there are
stakes here if I screw this up
I got a long time to wait if I get my
next connector press it in order to yeah
that's not the kind of guy I am
this is way better than the wet sponge
Freddy introduced me to this it's just
like what steel wool kind of thing with
a bunch of like solder flux in it and
then all your solder from the tip and
iron falls off a little dish does way
better job of cleaning the iron in our a
wet sponge does
[Applause]
not for the other side stripping wire
something about melting metal makes feel
really cool now I have to solder you can
look here you get above it you'll see is
the pin coming up and then I'm just
gonna do this
[Applause]
this plug I think I did a good job and
you put an xt60 connector on the other
end of that wire specifically female and
this is the part where you can't forget
to put the heat shrink tubing on the
wire before you solder people stop
this makes it a lot easier to connect
the tubes a lot to do is heat them up
stick them together
and then I'll have to do here squeeze it
down and once heat transfers through the
wires should get down to the solder if I
put in there and melt over here oops
just the pin twist inside of it
Jake is good carpentry and wood
craftsmanship like I've gotten pretty
decent at soldering and wire work
YouTube could build a house stick that
then you could Jakob build the frames
that I could put in the electrical see
being an electrician would be fun I
don't enjoy being electrician so clean
it's the cleanest connection I've done
yet it's like sitting right in there
it is your eyes do not deceive you it is
that connector I knew it it's all done
you can plug a battery in plug it in to
a laptop it's pretty sweet I here's the
thing I can't dial in the amperage until
I plug it into the laptop hey you're
leading right now aren't you
I'm taking on PLA so this is done I
could try it okay you could try it do
you want do you want to wait like five
minutes we're gonna go get the laptop in
the battery I was gonna take it over to
a doctor before it gets dark
okay well it is tomorrow
they are indeed yeah yes just down I am
yeah
see how there's a flat bit here with a
little indenture one more like that
anyway how long did it take you to find
that piece so I took me weeks to find
that piece that's odd
why are these wires pancreas oh they're
reversed over here too if red is red is
going to right well it's reversed
reversed so that means it's in the right
way at the yellow I'm going to fix that
right let me just double check all yeah
the flat side of the xt60 has to be
positive this has the flat side being
negative so if some saw some soldering
later so it's just the xt60 that has
flips the wires connected to the board
are fine goodness okay we can
well whatever I did I'm super paranoid
about this now but it looks yeah
flat is red red flat ok TTY but we're
getting nineteen point six to nineteen
point five volts so the computer is on
right now and we're at 62% on battery on
the inside of it okay has a chance of
frying this brand new origin laptop we
just got yeah in fact the chances are
quite high it'll probably be dead after
this no I'm not gonna fry it well don't
do that use another one talk to test it
now we need to use this one come see
well there's no other laptop with that
type of connector in the back of it yeah
there's only one that pulls that much
voltage and what this kind of connector
keep doing up that fan so here's my
thought
guess rest of it yeah let me all here
today to hopefully help us solve me and
share the blame if I fry his laptop his
laptop race call origin fad are you
running a voltage converter with his
here and now putting out nineteen point
five volts going into the plug it's all
soldered as you normally would this
stuff and you guys see anything that
could possibly fry this laptop yeah that
whole thing right there
I love how nervous deal but I'm not
nervous at all I think this is gonna go
completely fine aside from actually
putting the pins in there and being able
to get the actual voltage ring from
inside there we tested it inside there
we're getting the right voltage here
like it should be fine we made the
mistake of putting the wrong cables in
the wrong places but he fixed that now
oh that's good hey it's plugged in good
and we're showing it's charging I'm
pulling five amps going alright it's
working but it is pulling 11
consistently now yeah
we're doing it we're hitting 220 watts
if anything heating up well it's this
hot heat coming out the computer watts
and then just like one spot of this yeah
not too worried about them no I'm not
worried about that because the huge
heatsink has but I mean who these wires
aren't heating up
well there's little or not it but we're
talking about like an early we're not
talking about much you just put it in
front of this thing it could be like
right in the middle here it's like the
coolest that can be yeah not too much
not too much it's no more hot this stuff
okay so the real test here is to now
take this and plug it into our laptop
that hooked up to the vibe see where is
that it's next door this is beyond a
backpack yeah and all the power to
charge the run the laptop is also in the
backpack and you just mean they're
swinging swords I didn't continent
that's awesome dude that's so much
better
cuz I know they have it at the two bit
circus or is it wires everywhere oh they
have some that are backpack mounted and
they have some that are wires
what's the two bit circus the two bit
circus is that VR arcade down the street
that we all went to last week and you're
like no I'm gonna paint my minis instead
really alright so this is the production
laptop we're currently using for node we
run the VR system through it I've been
plugged it from the wall it's plugged
into the vibe right now we're going to
plug it into my mobile power supply and
I'm gonna run the yarn VR runs at full
frame rate and it works along your bones
like three years
all right the verdict is all the frame
rates let us move
runs great so I got the laptop working
at full power when it's not plugged into
the wall it's pulling all the
electricity from this battery and I've
tricked the laptop into thinking that
this battery in this system is actually
house power basically running to the
laptop so nothing's being down clock
everything's running at full power and
that can run VR in full frame rate now
the last they have to do is put this in
the backpack so that can be free to move
around that any wire is holding me down
[Music]
all right going into the game
you know this is more like relief that
it works as opposed to like celebration
I feel like the first man in space Ryan
Gosling first man in space I feel relief
that's working and I got plenty of
improvement to do to this rig I'll have
this is like it's hanging up up there
and it's time for us to record VR games
in this lock up hit play close the
laptop put it on and it likes Trump in
the middle of the room and I get to just
like do this that any entangled man must
be wherever I want
I got this up and running more work to
do to make it perfect and the closer
that place we sick the our games
subscribe wanna see me to continue
working on this and turn it into
something special and the ultimate video
game machine also next door here at
stress level zero Frannie's doing a lot
of VR development and they have five
pros and the 2.0 trackers which let you
have a much much bigger volume so
theoretically we could replicate the
building 3d and I could run through the
entire building wearing the VR I think
we're gonna try to do something like
that
shallots a note if you guys haven't
heard notice our gaming channel we do a
lot of the are there guys are working in
the videos right now you'll see this in
action on note considered hopping over
there and taking a look thanks for
watching everybody this is been like
three years to get this up and running
finally got it finally got the power
working now I just need to make it extra
slick and easy to use the challenge of
engineering